okay [ __ ] we are now going back to
where the [ __ ] we were it has been a
[ __ ] while so let's see what the [ __ ]
we are outside I don't even [ __ ]
remember
i cani cani right okay okay I hear [ __ ]
and that's what I do to a [ __ ] okay
what is this get this out of my face
okay heal me until I'm horny okay
ham me until I am alright is this wait
didn't we [ __ ] do this early maybe
not
it's music [ __ ] socks hold on let me
turn down this music because this music
J's s it's like giving me a [ __ ]
headache
okay I can't do this
and they set that up there
mmm-hmm the [ __ ]
man I could [ __ ] [ __ ] run faster
than this oh wait
can't that thing like speed up [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay okay I'm just going to speed this
[ __ ] up then where is that thing oh you
can press the W to go forward
why is that red
can't tell you do it
Oh check electric bot all right keep
that on for now
okay looks like how to go down there
manual override okay there's a second
one right where is it yeah this okay
time to get the [ __ ] out of here for
fourth and long okay what now
tonight on here
okay [ __ ] I get in there Oh louder [ __ ]
I hate those things don't mind if I do
don't mind if I do a [ __ ] empty what
the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
and you get this [ __ ] to go there button
[ __ ] it
what is that oh yeah you like that baby
you like that
which one I got to go then down there
now I donno if that emergency door
tonight okay
okay it says malfunctions not use check
power check track oh here we go
come on
the [ __ ]
you should move in
Oh check track
there we go
well I just [ __ ] always [ __ ] my pants
is now come on come on
shut holy [ __ ]
okay
oh [ __ ] get to the top
Oh walking yeah okay
no damn it again
there's that other one she says okay
and I doing this again
[Applause]
okay got got Jesus that's [ __ ] awful
can't bench
give them the old razzle-dazzle like I'm
loading
[Music]
now Chet Chet I need some help okay
but
okay
really did not do the stealth mode on
that just when I was starting to feel
lowly [ __ ] that guy scared the [ __ ] on
me
fixin to throw you a surprise party
better clear your dance card slick how
do I clean my dance card
I'd like to claim my dance card how do I
apply for a dance clearing
[ __ ] I need some house dog and an luck
into good hunting
but frankly it never it it out
what the [ __ ]
okay get not shut
now this is the main menu screen
what was that
shut [ __ ] it now they'd be around here
Oh Lord I'm DJ
I just should always empty
okay got
Chay's this [ __ ] this is a rocket I hear
someone okay okay
Jesus I have to tip the rocket no I'm
like outside
all right the [ __ ] do I go
I won't be needing this anymore okay
rocket is secured so what I use with
these what is this okay rock it secure
so if I go back down Oh
now I got a lock all these floors Jesus
okay I got to go back down to the bottom
and do it fuckin'-a okay good okay good
and okay cut why are we watching these
against
and I get the [ __ ] out of here
I don't see any elevators
however to ask
[ __ ] is that noise Wow okay I just
launched it now and I lot yet
oh okay this is open
get the [ __ ] out of there oh hold there
Bessie
[Music]
oh Jesus okay alright let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
here we go again
let's just get the [ __ ] out of here
ouch hen aids copper not may connect mmm
Bremen say with a ground zero
oh [ __ ] that's the rocket [ __ ] all
ready to go
okay where I got to go not here right
what's this
[Applause]
monsters tell ya what civilians for this
day of operation anything so bad Lance
yeah
I added plan up for those mobsters you
ask
checks with dicks yeah some civilians
now you know I think everyone actually
does like chicks with dicks like
contrary to what they say I do by the
story came through here via door right
what the [ __ ] there's nothing else up
here let's do it baby
why am I watching this thing on no wait
no get up Oh sky okay Webber
as when I get the yogurt
I saw that point to that well was that
whole subplot about I come away with
that okay
so I could use the head of a guard or
something well that's unfortunate
okay where do I go what do I say
probably in there right yeah oh [ __ ] Wow
I hear some shut
[Music]
okay ooh
get the [ __ ] out of here you [ __ ]
loading screens well no I let him show
up but that
you
okay now I'm underwater now I'm
underwater it is fine this is fine oh
[ __ ] no it's not
shut anyone have like an exit Saturday
and a one fuckin'-a and okay I guess I'm
going down
sit down here okay I'm trying this again
you can't get there that kind [ __ ]
I was closest with the other side I say
I say now
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay I've
got it here I cannot have this mother
[ __ ]
and war
okay okay
swimming
what the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] do I
I cannot oh [ __ ] yeah
okay
there's a whole
hmm okay let's see this where are we
going okay do not go in the water
did you see it yes I am it was hauled
from the Challenger Deep but I'm
positive that beast hasn't swam in
terrestrial waters until a week ago
there is a tranquilizer gun in this
office you are more than welcome to try
your neck at again the shark tank
either that work a chase
okay okay
[ __ ] I get out of here
and I got out of here
okay okay there we go
[ __ ] [ __ ] perhaps you should ready
more bullets I did it fell back are
that's that that was it
come on that thing was guarding come on
chief s so long I asked game
and chef
Oh five
all right let's do this jumping across
[ __ ] I like it boys stuff box I just
come from here okay I came here so I
probably ought to go the other way right
like that
he's that
I have to jump to that hole okay and try
that
shut
chat
but
okay good come on
Gordon Freeman it is you is high acid a
science team has been tracking your
progress with the Black Mesa security
system unfortunately so has the military
that suit of yours is full of tracking
devices still it's better than going
naked in history it's cold in there so
you'll have to hurry it could set your
suit power in a matter of moments
I can't you're bent on reaching the
lambda complex then you will want to
keep to the older industrial areas where
the security system is full of holes
it's worse for me so far
chase us I have to
[Music]
say that
I literally have no idea what we're
doing in the family I got a message for
you
make sure you don't what the [ __ ] was
that okay we're going to end it here
anyways thanks for watching y'all it has
been very interesting so far okay okay
bye
okay good boy psychobabble and we are
finally going back to this game Black
Mesa alright how do you know game I
actually have no idea where we are it
has been so long I guess apprehension I
guess I'll just keep playing until I get
to a new level
why does it need those tabs connection
with a server
okay so I'm trying out this new caption
thing - why is it like so chopping
nobody knows okay nobody knows I guess
what is let it
pull it on this Curt this remote
controller isn't working for some reason
one second
okay there we go there we go we got it I
literally have no idea where we are and
what is going on give me like a second
just to get my bearings can I have no
idea once again
uh hey guys jump okay Wow okay I have no
idea how do I
I don't hear that what is that
hold on I got look at the controls I
really have no idea what is going on
options okay I'm on a joystick I have no
idea it was a joystick yes okay I got
some batteries where does this go
holy smokes better gonna gun out okay I
guess we're just taking this baby steps
on it shouldn't let you be able to go
backwards right that'd be a little crazy
oh crap
okay I guess I'm just going this way
then yes where is everyone
I don't like the sound of this but I'm
bringing I'm bringing my piece okay I'm
breaking my piece okay really have no
idea where I'm going yeah yeah really
got no idea everywhere is a dead end
okay what is going on what is going on
how do I get again there
how clever
except I've no idea where I'm going is
there but Ted nothing here okay
Dave thank you this is what happens when
you like play a game and then come back
like a year later because I have no idea
what is going on I don't even know how
to run how
okay
back up there because that was a waste
of time
okay choose I don't know what those
numbers are and the captions okay I wish
I know but I don't know tank so can you
just leave me alone everyone please
can y'all does like me alone what what
is this first date charged ring charge
me up okay give this box a lot of people
wear like psychobabble like how do you
have time to just play video games all
day and I say I don't and I'm supposed
to be working right now okay I think I
can't win through their top-secret
nothing none of these things I marry top
secret okay
not exactly sure
so I'm going our way till I see some
aliens place you smiling I have no clue
what's going on how
oh Jesus
well what is that you're so ugly this
don't do a lot of damage
okay so that's at that end and I got
this right let's go over there
how do I go up there I say now I say
who's coughing over there I don't hear
that coughing okay
so here anything that's like sounds like
do here went to here once we're here ah
I say now I say now I get locked okay
this is a waste of time but what is
sound like I feel like I'm in a
multiplayer server by myself you got to
go up
here we go let's let's take things one
add time here okay
how'd it get over there
ow oh here we go
but I've done the majority of the damage
from my character this game for myself
surface access not really sure what that
put that dead alright to press up on
that for sure
okay
can I go down here now yeah I can or is
this a different area different area
okay
now this is gonna be a fun that's like
oh Jesus Jesus Christ Tom I said that's
the guy yeah you got him I got him
[ __ ] give me a hand here chase s
where we taking this Freeman guy stops
I'd requested a topside I can't help for
we got it when I just kill them now
and they find the body hey buddy
Alexa yeah thank okay okay
Jesus okay so apparently this Texas
Beach thing is not working whatsoever no
Tagus wanted here
okay this is the newest one a lot of
stuffs closing in here okay okay
crush it crush it gut that is disgusting
that is sad as well and I think that's a
jump over there go up there
now I knew it would hurt was that skull
thing I know weapons so thick sir well
what the heck okay
okay I want to sign there's an exit
there is no exit right how do I get up
there there a box or something how to
break
confusing confusing
I love confusing games you know it's
just like it's like two games for the
price of one you know like one game is
like the game another one is like trying
to figure out like how to play the game
you know maybe I got to go down there
again I'm gonna check this out real
quick what is this okay I'm here
what the heck is this and I am a mess up
in here okay so this isn't the way
obviously
I take this path real quick
you go this way
Wow okay I really have no idea what's
going on
I just speech thing locked again I think
it is okay if I have to go that side
Jesus
okay I'm going I'm going I'm going I see
that the website for the captions froze
again so this is just this is just what
I wanted you know just what I wanted
see here up
should've saw that
I got a pack on their high bike
okay how do I get down with that
breaking my legs see I think the sight
things like down again that's sad
that is sad it looks oh it looks so
promising it looks so promising great
I'm like in the desert this is horrible
great
hello or saying out
so the now it's going to pay now just me
walk in that desert and things just
packing thing to spawn and right in
front of me
that's fine you know I wanted a
challenge I yeah I wanted a challenge
okay it's getting a little more
predictable at least second I know what
Jax I'm adding in them Wow okay I just
got free and now I'm trying to get back
in that's fine I guess that's fine
should I put this